[Musique]
salut à tous on le sait tous la police
américaine est raciste et ses préjugés
la conduisent assassiner des
afro-américains innocents et désarmés
des mouvements citoyens comme black like
the matters dénonce cet état de fait et
si des militants qui se disent
antiraciste le disent c'est que ça doit
être vrai mais êtes vous vraiment sûr
que la police américaine commet des
crimes racistes ou bien le croyez vous
parce que tout le monde le répète comme
une vérité révélée et bien
personnellement pour en avoir le coeur
net je me suis penché sur les chiffres
des violences policières aux états unis
j'ai pris ce compilées par le huffington
post 2 janvier 2015 à novembre 2016 soit
1800 morts sur 23 mois
le film fun poste c'est l'équivalent de
libé aux états unis sur les 1800 morts
452 sont des blacks soit 25%
déjà je m'attendais à beaucoup plus de
blagues tué proportionnellement les afro
américains représentent 12% de la
population mais il représente 25 % des
pauvres et les personnes qui ont plus de
problèmes avec la police ce sont les
pauvres donc cette sur représentation
modérée n'est pas forcément surprenante
ensuite j'ai classé les états selon le
nombre de morts par habitant toutes
ethnies confondues pour voir si dans
certains états la police est plus
violente que dans d'autres et sur la
période le nombre varie de 1 à 6 2 1
pour six cent mille habitants à new york
jusqu'à 1 pour 80 ou 70 mille habitants
pour des états comme l'arizona puis j'ai
comptabilisé le nombre d'afro américains
tués par état et là j'ai été très
surpris je m'attendais à ce que les
états les plus violents et où il ya le
plus de blagues tués soit les mêmes et
surtout je pensais qu'il s'agirait des
états du vieux sud esclavagiste puis
ségrégationniste et bien en fait ce
n'est pas forcément le cas
prenons quelques exemples l'arizona est
un républicain pro-armes un des états
les plus violents les afro américains
ils représentent 4% de la population et
3 6 % des personnes tuées par la police
l'arkansas est un républicain du vieux
sud esclavagiste pro-armes pourtant très
moyennement violent 15% de black dans la
population
aucun mort new-jersey qui est un peu la
grande banlieue de new york
moyennement violent état démocrate
contrôle des armes stricte les blagues
représente 14% de la population et 40 %
des morts
californie états démocrate
très progressiste contrôle des armes
stricte et blacks sont 6 % de la
population mais 40% des morts illinois
états démocrate contrôle des armes
strictes les blacks sont 15% de la
population et 60 % des tués par la
police
encore deux exemples alabama état
républicain je suis d'esclavagistes très
violent pro armes
les blacks sont 26% de la population 32%
des morts la différence n'est
probablement pas significatives et
wyoming états républicains pro armes
ultra violent quasiment pas
d'afro-américains fat black tués
conclusion il n'ya pas forcément de
corrélation entre populations noires et
tir mortel de la police ni entre
violence et contrôle des armes ou encore
entre violence et couleur politique
pas mal de nos stéréotypes prennent
l'eau les flics du vieux sud qu'on
imagine facilement être des red neck de
gros beaufs racistes
adepte des gros gun et lui ont tiré
d'abord on discute ensuite ne sont pas
responsables d'une surmortalité chez les
afro-américains et ce alors même que ces
états concentrent une importante
population noire et pauvre
de quoi faire douter de la vision d'une
police adeptes du meurtre raciste de
plus il faut dire quelques mots sur le
contexte de tous ces morts sur les 450
de blagues tuées pendant ces 23 mois
seulement 54 n'avait pas d'armes et 259
avait une arme à feu les autres avaient
soit une arme blanche soit foncé en
voiture ce qu'on pourrait réellement
considérer comme des victimes de bavures
des innocents désarmés soit en fait
entre 20 et 30 par an et encore toute
personne désarmée n'est pas forcément
pacifique
ces chiffres m'ont surpris ils m'ont
même tellement surpris qu'à l'époque
quand j'ai fait les calculs en novembre
2016 j'ai décidé de ne pas faire des
vidéos dessus
ils vont tellement l'encontre des
croyances populaires comme quoi la
police américaine commettraient des
crimes racistes que j'ai préféré ne rien
faire très clairement je me suis censuré
et puis récemment je suis tombé sur une
étude réalisée par un professeur de
harvard portant sur la question des
violences policières aux états unis
selon la race des citoyens concernés lui
a utilisé des données de la police
allant de 1996 à 2011 regroupant les
données de millions d'interactions
police citoyens avec des informations
très précises comme la race du citoyen
et du policier incriminé le type d'armes
utilisé le niveau de violence l'âge des
protagonistes leur niveau social etc
freier à créer des formules qui
permettent de prendre en compte ces
nombreux critères et au final ces
calculs permettent de comparer
globalement les interactions entre
police les personnes de race différente
toutes choses égales par ailleurs il a
fait des tests statistiques bien plus
complexe que moi et devinez quoi il
arrive à la même conclusion il n'ya pas
de surmortalité des blacks lors des
interventions policières et lui aussi a
été très surpris par ses propres
résultats et ce chercheur malgré ses
résultats ce n'est pas un membre du ku
klux klan roland fryer c'est son nom est
afro-américain
je vous propose maintenant de survoler
son étude et jeudi survolez parce
qu'elle contient 50 pages de
commentaires d'analystes et de méthodes
et autant d'un ex tout d'abord il s'est
intéressé à l'utilisation de la force
par la police lors des interpellations
les chiffres de fryer montre qu'il ya un
usage plus important de la petite
violence mise à terre plaquages contre
un mur et c'est pour neutraliser les
suspects noirs ou hispaniques quand le
policier blanc ce qu'on ne retrouve pas
avec des officiers noir face à un
suspect blanc ce qui pourrait accréditer
la thèse d'une discrimination de la part
des policiers blancs par contre il note
que plus la violence non létales
augmente moins il ya de discrimination
freier apporte une hypothèse sous forme
économique pour expliquer ce résultat le
coût de la petite violence est moindre
que celui d'une grande violence
lors de l'interpellation le policier
risque bien moins de problèmes
hiérarchique ou judiciaire
en remettant un suspect contre le mur
quand le taser et puis il passe ensuite
aux interpellations qui tourne mal et où
il ya des coups de feu mortels de la
part de la police
et là les résultats sont surprenants les
afro américains ont 23 % de chances de
moins que les blancs d'être victime de
tirs policiers la situation égale et
policiers ont 46 % de chances en moins
de tirer si la personne et noirs les
blancs proportionnellement
donc plus chouchouté par la police en
situation extrême les officiers noirs
eux ont plus de chance de tuer un blanc
désarmés que des officiers blancs de
tuer un noir désarmé
donc les meurtres policier raciste de
masse aujourd'hui relève du fantasme et
du discours politique
les associations comme blake lively
matters n'ont donc pas de raison
d'exister
d'ailleurs en conclusion freier apporte
un conseil pas très politiquement
correct il conseille la black eyed
matters et consorts plutôt que de se
focaliser sur les comportements de la
police à s'interroger sur les
comportements de la communauté noire
alors pourquoi nous certes on ce
discours sur les violences policières
alors que globalement les bavures s'ils
existent sont ultra minoritaires
et bien tout d'abord ce discours trouve
une résonance dans l'histoire récente
des états unis effectivement même après
les mouvements pour les droits civiques
longtemps la police avait des
comportements racistes et puis surtout
la gauche aux états unis à partir des
années 60 a remplacé la question sociale
par la question raciale
par exemple en 1965 patrick meehan un
sociologue avait remis un rapport au
président de l'époque où il expliquait
que le problème de la communauté noire
était la dislocation des familles
qu'engendrait la pauvreté les familles
ils sont souvent monoparentales avec une
mère qui doit à la fois éduquer ses
enfants et travailler pour subvenir à
leurs besoins
money and expliqué qu'il fallait
redonner du travail aux hommes noirs
pour leur redonner leur dignité et leur
statut de pater familias et ainsi
stabiliser les familles
aujourd'hui on le sait les familles
monoparentales pauvres effectivement
génère plus de délinquance que les
familles biparentales mais à l'époque
tout le monde a crié au racisme et
parfois aussi au sexisme
résultat le rapport a été enterré au
profit de politiques de discrimination
positive et 50 ans après la situation de
la communauté noire n'a pas évolué et
dans les états démocrate
on l'a vu la police n'est pas forcément
moins violentes les violences des
policiers blancs dans les petits actes
de maintien de l'ordre peuvent aussi
cacher une autre réalité que le racisme
la violence endémique dans la communauté
noire
le gangsta rap ce n'est pas qu'une
imagerie dans les années 90 une partie
des rappeurs afro américains est tombé
sous les balles lors de règlements de
comptes
les premiers tueurs de noir ce sont les
noirs en 2015 2000 blacks ont été tués
par des blacks
il faut aussi savoir qu'en 2016 soixante
quatre policiers ont été tués par balles
dont 21 tomber dans des embuscades dans
ce contexte un policier blanc qui tue un
enfant afro-américain de 10
qui avait un pistolet en plastique au
risque de choquer ça peut être mais ce
n'est pas forcément une bavure
et au final le discours victimaire
permet à la fois d'attirer le vote noir
à gauche de jouer sur la culpabilité
raciale des blancs et évite d'aborder
ses problèmes internes à la communauté
noire
le tout sans avoir à parler de social
aujourd'hui ce genre de stratégie
consistant à renvoyer le tout problème à
une question raciale émerge aussi à
gauche en france
il serait dommage de se priver de
l'expérience américaine alors sachez le
d'un point de vue de l'action publique
et politique
c'est une impasse ces discours qui
mélange classes et races dans un gloubi
boulga absolument victimaire sont certes
un bon filon électorale mais ne règle
aucun problème sur le terrain on l'a vu
les états démocrates ne sont pas
forcément moins violent envers la
communauté noire que les états
républicains
bref cette vidéo est terminée j'espère
qu'elle vous aura appris des choses si
c'est le cas n'hésitez pas à la partager
et à vous abonner et moi je vous dis à
la prochaine
[Musique]